[Music]
your ex I have to ask you your ex
Roseanne you're running for president
she not she's running for president yeah
you give us your take would Roseanne
make a good present well well now as she
is yeah
I tell ya I gotta say she's not worried
about it exactly you're talking about
the former governor of California
we're scared to her that I have a him no
she's been she said she said you know
what heard she's got the credentials she
has sang the national anthem oh I don't
have to deal with me what if she has a
point is she's someone who's edition
worker she's very talented but there's
gonna be a day when she doesn't want to
get up but you know I'm not getting up
on it well there might be a war well you
do it you know cabinet you're all fired
yeah that'll happen that will happen
[Applause]
I just know she's not feeling it
okay you know she was she ran really
hard for president hurt he paid for a
couple days been like a three-day run
for president yeah and now she's done
okay
I'm never gonna tell you anything in
confidence my big redneck vacation yes
very show the highest-rated show ever on
CMT in the history seat which is nice
and and there that we have a nice family
their names the Clampetts it's not a
fake thing and then we put them in a
fight baby no what happened you took a
real family wrote an ex a whole big
family about like 12 from Arkansas yep
or no Louisiana whatever anyway we put
them in the Hamptons in a five million
dollar house for the summer and let the
cameras roll and it's it's really
interesting because they're you know
first there are extra red Nikki that's
how it is when you get these subcultures
extra rednecky and the Hamptonites for
extra social ID so they didn't get along
and now you see them kind of blend in
and it's a story of America my friend I
[Laughter]
can't believe you were